[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what a tough day but at least they get
to come home to what matters most family
hi honey hi babe how was work that's
pretty good I mean I don't know all the
shows run together after a while
oh you stopped it I'm sure it was an
extra-special show and you were
hilarious yeah I guess
is Abby home I'd love to say hello to
Abby Conan she's gone again Abby's gone
no don't tell me she's hanging out with
the kids in row three again
happy happy god dammit are you are you
studying for the LSAT again you're the
only father in the world angry at his
daughter for wanting to be a lawyer
young lady you are not gonna become a
lawyer you do not do that to me please
Oh easy undercoated Abby you listen to
me you're gonna become a top show host
like like me like my father and his
father before him
a talk-show host so I can do terrible
jokes about Papa John's and pulling out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how dare you
I said cookies you say honest quiet
listen those terrible jokes paid for
your private school education well I
don't want your blood money anymore
and I'm tired of being here now if
you'll excuse me me and my friends are
going somewhere we can enjoy ourselves
oh yeah enjoy yourselves and where is
that an Ellen taping
[Applause]
mrs. Kony new this spring on TBS
[Applause]
it don't look like tears anyway
[Applause]
you